en jean tu peux t'habiller comme tu veux
quoi par exemple quand tu vas dans un
bureau tu as la cravate et tout
intellectuel quoi et quand tu vas en
boum je sais pas gros pull avec le jean
disco quoi
[Musique]
étonnant uniforme du jeans délavé rien
que du jean du pantalon à la chemise en
passant par le maillot de bain et les
chaussures être jeans des pieds à la
tête c'est ce que propose la plupart des
boutiques de mode
[Musique]
préféré parce qu'il se
détend
les jeunes et les moins jeunes suivent
ce conseil du bleu pâle presque blanc
aux Marines éclaircit il mêle les jeans
dans une graduation subtile du délavage
comme si chaque pantalon chaque blouson
avait sa propre histoire était chargé
d'un parfum d'aventure
une façon d'oublier le monde du travail
posséder un jeans délavé c'est montrer
que depuis longtemps on vit en plein air
dans la nature qu'on appartient à
l'aristocratie de ceux qui ont acquis ce
privilège une fois de plus les jeunes
loups du prêt-à-porter triomphe puisque
aujourd'hui l'horreur du 9 est devenue
un phénomène de masse d'abord limité et
un petit nombre de snob cette idée
d'associer le 9 au vulgaire a fait son
chemin qu'est-ce qui vous guide dans le
choix de vos vêtements pour être comme
nos copains et différents des gens qui
sont pas dans quel genre de boutique
choisissez-vous vos vêtements
[Musique]
pratique moi je sais que personnellement
je la pratiquement jamais et par exemple
dans un autre pantalon les effilochures
que j'ai parlé j'aurais été obligé
pratiquement de les raccommoder ou de
faire quelque chose il se trouve qu'avec
un blue jeans je peux me permettre c'est
une sorte de carte blanche je peux me
permettre d'aller n'importe comment
pratiquement
après l'Europe les pays de l'Est à leur
tour sont touchés par la mode du blues
jeans rapporte les touristes qui
racontent qu'en Union soviétique les
jeans font prime sur le marché parallèle
ce n'est plus une mode c'est un
phénomène social qui touche désormais le
monde entier
vous êtes le jean le plus cher du monde
alors là dessus je suis très content je
suis le plus cher du monde bon et je
suis le pape et puis tout va bien olé
simplement on a contribué fortement à
justement un phénomène là au phénomène
du jean en France enfin en France et
maintenant bon et pas aux États-Unis
puisque les États-Unis sont en train de
ils ont ils ont bouclé la boucle en
définitif
voilà l'avenir c'est plutôt renouer avec
le pantalon enfin le pantalon
traditionnel de du chercheur d'or
puisque on définit c'est une grande
boucle et qu'on va la boucler il sera
beaucoup plus là il sera beaucoup plus
large ici parce qu'on a besoin de
confort on comprend que c'est bien beau
on est bien on est bien on est bien
serré mais c'est s'il était un peu plus
large comme ça
un petit peu décollé du genou pour
permettre pour permettre de s'installer
les voitures bases et peut-être étroit
du bas pour pouvoir porter bon mais
pourquoi pas des pourquoi pas des
Rangers le fait que ensuite il décolore
ça c'est une chose et par ailleurs bon
c'est c'est ça une solidité fantastique
pas une cigarette une cigarette c'est
quand même c'est chaud
on la met sur le je la mets sur mon
pantalon là je laisse bon laisse on
laisse encore je frotte bon il y a rien
monte c'est vachement c'est très c'est
vraiment constant je dirais que le jeans
c'est un peu comme un passeport
c'est justement ce qui vous évite d'être
définie dans une catégorie particulière
même si finalement le gin c'est aussi
une catégorie mais par rapport aux
autres types de vêtements c'est
probablement la catégorie la plus
ouverte qui soit donc pour reprendre
cette idée de passeport c'est un
passeport j'irai social quel que soit
les couches sociales vous pouvez porter
votre jean c'est un passeport je dirais
ces cancers ne l'accompagnent la ville
donc dans l'espace est aussi un
passeport c'est aussi un passeport je
dirais sexuel c'est à dire que
je dirais presque par nature le jeans
c'est le vêtement androgyne ce que l'on
montre à la publicité en ce moment ce
que la publicité monte c'est
les fesses c'est-à-dire la chose
sexuelle je veux pas dire organe le
morceau du corps
sexuel et pouvant avoir une fonction
hérogène que les hommes et les femmes
ont en commun à ce niveau il est bien
certain que c'est les vêtements par
excellence de l'unisexe j'ai acheté mon
premier Jean à 15 ans et c'était quelque
chose de très très nouveau pour moi dans
la mesure où j'étais dans une école
uniforme bleue marine et où le bougie ne
représentait quelque chose de
complètement différent des choses de
beaucoup plus sportif de beaucoup plus
libre et par rapport à mes vêtements
quotidiens et donc c'était vraiment bon
c'était vraiment un plaisir de le porter
et de me dire bon je changeais
totalement de sens de signification et
aujourd'hui le jean de Catherine c'est
également un vêtement qui lui donne plus
de liberté et un vêtement plus masculin
aujourd'hui oui certainement
mais elle ne porte pas de la même façon
je crois c'est surtout dans la journée
mais elle fait encore un effort pour
s'habiller pour les soirées
mais le jean de toutes les façons ça
peut être quelque chose de ça peut être
quelque chose de d'habiller c'est à dire
j'aurai un certain plaisir à le mettre à
le mettre le matin de l'accorder avec
d'autres choses et puis le soir ça peut
être aussi quelque chose de sexy de
sortir en boîte avec de sortir en boîte
avec un joli blue de jeans bien serré
des bougies vous en avez combien
on a une quinzaine à nous deux
à nous deux parce qu'en fait on a une
toute petite différence de poids mais on
interchange nos budget
porte les siens et Catherine qui les
achète au début 9 elle les met un
certain temps et puis je m'aperçois que
à partir du moment où ils sont bien fait
elle mais au fond du placard à ce moment
là je l'ai récupéré et ils sont un matin
aussi on est remonté en amont on
s'aperçu que d'un jean à usage
complètement confidentiel c'était devenu
le jean d'une certaine jeunesse
contestataire une époque de nez et
aujourd'hui c'est devenu le jean de
toute la jeunesse c'est curieux de dire
que le jean est un mode de ou un signe
de révolte de la jeunesse contre contre
la famille ou une façon de se démarquer
enfin je crois que c'est exactement
l'inverse c'est plus une liberté
d'exprimer son individualité c'est à
dire se sentir bien dans ses vêtements
s'exprimer être différent des adultes
exprimer sa différence mais c'est avant
tout se sentir bien soi-même je crois
que le public le plus large on peut le
compter en gros de
14-15 ans jusqu'à 25 ans je crois que ça
c'est le gros ce que nous appelons dans
notre jargon le cœur de cible à partir
d'un élément masculin qui est le jean de
l'origine
finalement la jeune fille va avoir envie
de séduire pour nous ça correspond à ce
que nous avons appelé une population de
suiveuse qui sont des jeunes qui suivent
au plus près la mode
il y a aussi une autre un autre style
qui est intéressant à regarder pour nous
c'est justement ce qu'on a appelé le
jean des créatives elles peuvent aussi
de la soie du cuir toutes sortes de
choses qui finalement vont complètement
transgresser le jean et en faire quelque
chose de très très insolite chaque femme
sait trouver justement le petit élément
qui va lui permettre de s'approprier et
finalement de déterminer un look
personnel tu peux t'habiller comme tu
veux quoi par exemple quand tu vas dans
un bureau tu as la cravate et tout
intellectuel quoi et quand tu vas en
boum je sais pas à gros pull avec le
jean disco quoi
moi j'aime bien parce que surtout
l'élastique tu peux faire n'importe quel
mouvement ça te sert pas
puis ça fait bien circuler le sang enfin
mes copines ils me disent c'est dur à
retirer mais je dis bof
quand c'est des pantalons élastiques
c'est pas dur
la preuve
[Musique]